[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast things
are
they're they're moving a pace i'm a
little behind the eight ball
i have just showered my hair is gonna
dry there's no telling what is about to
happen
hair wise at least i think you just said
what it's about to happen it's about to
dry
well hopefully watching hair dry is less
interesting than watching paint dry
oh it's not a good it's not a good
activity but the thing is sometimes with
me
this hair it dries in a way that i have
to start over i've got to go back to bed
and get up
shower again and uh get everything right
i do feel like this is one of the ways
in which we are gender well reversed
i feel like you think about your hair a
lot more than i do i really think about
your hair no i like your hell of your
hair
no no it's it's it's not like that i'm
not focused on it it's just that it does
crazy things that elicit comments from
people
i think the comments from the people are
the crazy things
okay all right well i'm willing to go
that's what i think
i think they're jealous jealous
well i have i have wondered if some of
the nastier comments on youtube
are the result of the bald community
rising up against those of us with more
than our allotment of hair
that's right all right so it's episode
75
spring has sprung here in the pacific
northwest
um we were gonna start with a few
announcements talk about where we're
going today and then just embark so
where we're going today first before the
announcements we're going to talk a
little bit about
privacy and game cameras um
ask if we should be allowing children to
transition medically and surgically a
topic that we
have returned to over and over again but
it is so of the moment
and uh so important in our estimation
that we're going back there
um we're going to talk a little bit
about the fda approval of a new drug to
treat adhd
a remarkable finding about how parent
intervention affects children
um you're going to talk a little bit
about a a
kerfuffle between tanahisi coats and
jordan peterson
and then we'll talk about sunlight yeah
that sounds perfect
all right i believe it is spring has
spranged though it's really
is that what you think versus hung when
you're talking about a person well you
go ahead and think that all right
fair enough all right um announcements
we as as as usual we encourage you to
subscribe to like
to go to our patreons and and become our
patrons there
and um also last week we introduced
doing ads we don't have any ads today
we're not going to probably for the rest
of this month but we are going to
start doing paid ads but we wanted to be
clear in a way that we thought we were
clear last time but maybe
weren't about the the the nature of
those ads one of which
is there will always be an audio
indicator both before and after anything
that is paid
um and also if you're watching on
youtube there'll be that green border
around it so if you don't see the green
border it is not a paid ad and that and
and for our first time we spent some
time you know we spent a
much longer time on on the paid ads than
we will in the future which will just be
you know a minute or two
yeah and i would just say this is really
a fail-safe measure
because the important thing is that we
are not motivated to say things that we
wouldn't say
um which means that we have to be ultra
selective and
the uh the fact that we will only
endorse things that we actually think
are
worth your while that's the first layer
of protection the second layer of
protection is that you'll
know unambiguously when we are speaking
uh
from that perspective versus everything
else we say
um so anyway doubly protected yeah why
is one more thing on that is that um
behind behind the curtain something that
i certainly wasn't aware of and i'm not
sure i'd ever thought of before we were
doing this and when i was listening to
podcasts and hearing ads and
you know i would hear many of the same
products come up in ads in wildly
different podcasts
um and you know that that's because
there's some
number of of vendors out there who are
interested in advertising on these
things and it's not like you know we
have a private list
of um things that we use that we would
advertise for
um that aren't an option because those
companies don't don't
advertise on podcasts so um we are being
selective within a rather already a
narrow
um a narrow grouping yep all right all
right
um do you wanna say anything more about
that or no i think i mean i think that's
pretty much it i just want people to
understand uh you know by and large the
reaction was
quite positive uh both people were
accepting of the fact of us doing ads
and um they liked the the way we did it
where we did a bunch of pro bono ads
both for and against certain
products and services i certainly had
fun with that yeah it was it was fun
um there was one person who
uh was concerned about knowing when we
were
motivated by um by an advertiser to say
things
so this is in large measure responsive
to the fact that that is a legitimate
concern
absolutely that um we would share but it
is also important i think to say
we didn't choose to do this that this is
the result of the fact that our new
uh way of earning a living in the world
is subject to
um effective unilateral veto power by
platforms means that we have to think
about how we approach the world
differently we don't have
a salary or a court that we can go to uh
if our employer treats us badly we are
um functioning uh in a way in which
there's no safety net and so anyway
i just hope people will understand
there's an interesting longer
conversation to be had there actually
you
you you caused me to throw an error a
little bit when you said we did not
choose to do this because obviously at
one level
at the narrow level we did absolutely
choose you know we could have said no
um as you know as we did for a while um
but there is there's sort of uh you know
we have employed this language before
over in phylogenetic systematics the
science of trying to figure out um the
deep history of who's related to whom
in in evolution um there you can talk
about the sense of structure the narrow
sense of a term and the senzu lotto the
broader sense of a term and
you know in the sense who strictos sense
we of course chose
um and you are pointing out that at the
systemic level we are now we are all
living in a system in which much of our
sensulato level of choice
is being restricted behind the scenes
and that's in fact kind of a meta theme
of of what we are doing here is talking
about a restriction of choice
while people point out little choices
that we're allowed to make and saying
see you have full choice like no no
no no we don't just because there's
narrow choice sensor's choice sensor
stricto
does not mean that we are retaining the
full level of choice since ulato
um that we would uh claim to not just
hope for but deserve
in a free democracy well when i said uh
that we didn't choose this i was
specifically thinking
of the fact that we had what appeared to
be
secure salaries and jobs
and then our institution melted down in
a way that made it impossible to
continue teaching there so we didn't
choose for our institution to do that in
fact we tried to prevent it from doing
that
and having had our institution uh
disintegrate
we had to find another way of earning a
living and so i i don't feel that that
was
choice of course how we chose to um to
show up in the world as podcasters
was uh obviously choice at one level
all right all right so you wanted to
start um by picking up on something that
you did
a uh a pro bono ad for last week i'm
talking about trail cameras and also
privacy
yeah so we did get a comment from
somebody that
again because it resonates with things
that you and i
feel i thought uh deserved
coverage somebody said they hated the
idea of trail cameras
in nature areas because it was the death
of privacy and you and i
absolutely feel this way as you
mentioned last week
when we are at field stations in the
tropics people very often use these
things as research tools
and the fact that you happen on a camera
and that you know that it captures
you has some impact and it's negative
but
the value of what is gleaned from these
cameras is so immense that we all
understand
it makes sense that they are there one
of the things that's true at least at
tippatini the field station in the
ecuador and amazon which we refer in
where we've spent a fair bit of time
is that not only do cameras exist as
part of an ongoing
very valuable research project to
actually monitor and um
and and describe the charismatic
megafauna mostly
but there's always a sign before a
camera on the trail too so you actually
know before you're about to stumble into
um what's called a camera trap and uh
and get flashed and know that you are
thus immortalized right now i did want
to point out though that in the case of
what i've been doing
this is not a serious issue because
i have been placing the cameras in
places that they don't capture
people i'm not placing them on trails
that are being
used by people so literally the only
people in several weeks now
of using these camera traps the only
people i've captured are two people who
were illegally
fishing in the reserve right so these
are people who
are doing something that is uh
destructive of
nature what i'm doing you know there is
some downside to it i will say i try to
compensate for whatever the
impact of my presence there is by
removing a significant piece of trash
from the reserve each time i go um the
reserve is actually pretty nice doesn't
have a lot of trash so it takes some
searching on my part but
i can take it out but the uh the thing
is the camera
traps are set in a way as to only
capture wildlife except in the case of
these two
illegal fishermen um
now you know no fisherman can be illegal
zach zack i called you zac
you did call me zac that's weird okay
i'm just gonna i'm gonna move
right past it um but the uh yeah you've
told me that uh
our voices increasingly sound alike i
actually do not confuse you in any way
but
parents will know that um in in
households with a lot of
individuals the names somehow sometimes
get swapped so
yes anyway uh my my point was just a
joke on the
you know the objection right calling
people illegal immigrants
and shortening it to illegals is um is
dehumanizing
yes uh these are illegal
is it pescetarians or is that no that's
people who eat fish well presumably but
i'm assuming these people eat fish so
but pescatarians i think are people who
are
vegetarians but also eat fish lazy lazy
and a vegetarian
these are piscivores no no they're
fishermen they're fishermen all right
they're anglers
i don't know what they're angling for
well i started with the with the failed
language so now we're just going to just
uh yeah so all right
so i did want to show some things so
part of the
intrigue of these cameras is that they
actually allow you to nail down
features of animal behavior that are
very difficult to nail down
otherwise and i completely forgot in
our discussion last week that i am oddly
one of
the early pioneers in this field it
wasn't camera traps camera traps are now
an object that you buy and it holds an
sd card and
batteries and all of that but when i was
doing my dissertation work as
as you well know um i was
uh working on tent making bats and 10
minutes bats
tent making is a behavior that had never
been seen by humans in fact
humans had a misunderstanding about how
the bats did it because we the tents
were commonly seen and were well
described in many cases
but the fact that the animals would
never do it when a human being was
watching meant that people had
guessed and they had guessed wrong so um
i
uh in part on the suggestion of a friend
of ours john cooley
started to use bank surveillance cameras
which happened to be
sensitive in the infrared spectrum and i
soldered this this is like the mid-90s
yeah the mid-90s
i soldered together and i did some
experiments i have some of the crude
experiments that i started with i
built an illuminator made of television
remote
leds that i strung together at first i
thought it wasn't going to take very
many you know
1 2 8 10. it turned out my final design
had 247 leds
um that number was necessary to get the
voltages right
but anyway i made it was that in fact
the bat bright 2000
that was the bat bright 4000 it's that
bright 2000 was not bright enough
um but in any case uh so i made the bat
bright 4000 and i used these
surveillance cameras and i
hung out in the forest i and this was in
the middle of the panama canal middle of
the panama canal
i was uh adept enough at finding these
tents that i was able to find
one that was partially had just begun to
be constructed i was able to
tell that a bat was working on this leaf
but that it wasn't done
so this is not the place for a full
curriculum
in tintpat biology but i think um people
are imagining like pop tents
like you there's a there's a whole lot
of imagining we will return to this i i
will dig up some video and show
but um a tent is a large understory leaf
that has been or there's actually one
style of tent that involves multiple
leaves but
a large understory leaf that has been
modified so that it collapses in a very
regular way
that obscures the bats protects them
from rain etc we can talk more about why
they do that another time
but anyway it uh you know at the point
that um
i don't know night shot or whatever it
is started showing up on cameras it was
like oh yeah actually i was doing that
you know with
that 12 volt car battery and a bank
surveillance camera and
leds from uh television remotes and all
that
but okay so these things are very useful
at seeing things you can't see
i couldn't have watched the traffic
cameras yeah i couldn't have watched the
bats make the tent
um if i had been close enough to see it
i had to be at a distance in order for
the bats to do it which meant that i
needed to use some
technology just to clarify for the
non-animal behaviorists they wouldn't do
it if you were right there right you
needed to be far enough away that they
weren't thrown by your presence
the reason that humans had never seen
bats like a tent was not for lack of
effort was that everything you would do
in order to observe it scared the bats
off they're
very sensitive about it so anyway i
would do it at a distance and in order
that
i wouldn't just leave a light there and
a regular camera which would also
disturb them
i used infrared light which they can't
see so anyway that's the basis of these
these trail cameras now um so let me
just show you some of the things that
we've captured
recently zach do you want to show the uh
first of the
um no no not that one um
show the uh oh show the beaver one
so i set up a camera
on a um
[Music]
on a uh burrow not
knowing what of several animals were
inhabiting the burrow
yeah um so show this one so this is
not the primary animal i see associated
with this burrow but
that's a very clear image of a beaver
entering this burrow
um he's just like showing off his tail
in case you were at all wondering what
was going on
right now this camera shoots both day
and night um
and so that's it that was last night
that was april 10th
yeah like 2 a.m yes uh it
sends me videos um okay now
show the second one from that borough
now here that's interesting i was not
expecting to see this animal here at all
that was an otter okay it's not a beaver
at the same
entrance now i don't though that was
also night
now show the diurnal one facing the
other direction
um
[Music]
now this is the animal that i thought
was responsible for
this burrow and that i expected to see
this
is a nutria so a nutria
and you're sure that the second one that
you showed was an otter not an atria
absolutely i haven't looked at it you
can tell because the tails
it's fluffy radically different it has a
like a triangular so the otter has a
triangular shaped tail the nutrient has
a rat like tail and the beaver has the
unmistakable yeah
flat tail conic otters have like a
conical tail
right so a this raises all kinds of
interesting questions
you've got these three species now the
nutria and the otter i and the nutria
and the beaver
are probably uh close competitors of
each other the otter being a carnivore
so the nutria and the beaver are both
rodents
um and uh probably insect divorce though
oh well i know beaver's not necessarily
but
nutria is probably an insectophorus i
don't think so i don't think so but in
any case
very odd to see them sharing uh a burrow
nutria is invasive here which we will
get back to i think this is also a very
interesting question and then the otter
which is native here that's a river
otter of course um
although in the puget sound the
otters even though it's saltwater are
river otters off the coast they are sea
otters which are quite different but
in any case it's very interesting to see
these three species of large
moderately large-bodied mammals sharing
the same bro system how are they
interacting
uh how much conflict is there i mean
they're literally underground you know
are they are they sharing or
are one or two of them exploring
occupied nope not for me
move move along you know that's
obviously an exercise
in um exploration that organisms that do
use burrows
engage in sure but i'm virtually certain
that's not going on
here because uh i set this up that
this it's actually a burro system okay
so there are like
five or six entrances that i've found to
these burrows and i set up on the one
that looked to be the most
active but it's quite clear a
these cameras would have seen the
animals retreat had they done so
quickly um my guess is that they could
have gone at a different
entrance right but all these animals a
they weren't
tentative going into the burrow b
what are the chances that i happen to
capture
them exploring all at the same time i
set this up in the case of in
in a matter of two days i saw all of
this
activity and so this seems like just
regular activity it doesn't seem
extraordinary
all right so a mixed living burrow yeah
a mixed living bro
it raises interesting questions somebody
may know the answer but in any case
this is the way actually good um field
work
goes is that everything you discover
just
starts raising questions and you can
imagine what those questions would begin
to unfold
uh like if you were you know involved in
dissertation work rather than just
you know curiosity as is the case here
but all right let's let's um
get back to the question of the nutria
you and i had this discussion
a couple of nights ago the nutria are
invasive
in uh in oregon and increasingly in much
of north america they are
neotropical rodents and there's
something surprising about the fact that
they are successful in invading which is
that
almost everything that is tropical
would be limited by climate and unable
to invade
temperate habitats because even if they
would do fine in the summer and maybe
spring and fall the winter would be too
cold and it would kill them so what is
put another way
temperate habitats tend to be
uninvisible by tropical organisms
but the inverse is differently true
well let's put it this way the uh the
great ecologist
macarthur um uh
famously he was an ornithologist
famously observed something that i then
uh not knowing that he had said this
rediscovered in my trying to figure out
why there were more species as you got
towards the equator which
seems like a question we should all know
the answer to but strangely is one in
which there is not yet a consensus
though i did advance what i think is the
right answer in my dissertation but
in any case what macarthur said was
that species tend to be limited on the
northern end of their range
by climate and on the southern end of
their range by competition
so and he was talking with the northern
hemispheric bias so that so
put that more generally species are
limited
at the more at the end of their range
towards the poles
uh competition and at the end of their
range no other way
at the end of the range towards the
polls by weather or climate climate
um and at the end of the range towards
um the equator by competition by
competition exactly so what the heck is
freeing the nutria
to um to invade north america
and you and i had a discussion in which
i think we came up with something
quite useful right so um your point
i think was that i asked you um
whether or not it was about it being
aquatic that that basically
um a largely water-dwelling organism
might have the variability in climate in
the temperate zones
somewhat mitigated someone must be able
to invade at least
farther into the more extreme um
you know towards the pole end of its
range right so
uh just to make that clear water
mitigates
weather because water has such a high
specific heat
water tends to cause a reduction in
fluctuation of temperatures so the
coasts tend to be more stable
than inland which tends to be much more
variable etc and so
you suggested and i think this is part
of the answer is that places that
because these are
always found near water these are
semi-aquatic rodents they spend a lot of
time swimming and i'll
dig up some pictures of them swimming
around at some point but um the uh
the fact of them living in habitats that
are always near water
mitigates the weather somewhat but i
also wonder and we talked about this too
whether the fact of them being in the
water itself doesn't drive the evolution
of their capacity to preserve heat in a
way that other creatures that simply
near
lived near water wouldn't exactly
because water is so good at robbing the
body of heat that every animal that
lives
in the water has mechanisms you know
beaver now uh
otter pelts for example are incredibly
dense
right they effectively are function like
a wetsuit to to allow the animal to
trap heat so the water the aquatic
environment may both be mitigating a
variability
in in climate and also lead to a
robustness which could even be an
anti-fragility with regard to
extreme climate right so this leads to
uh that's a hypothesis about what's
going on two
two hypotheses that are consistent with
each other they're not mutually
exclusive
and it leads to a clear prediction which
is that when
animals invade uh habitats
which they are expected to be limited by
climate that they
those that invade are more likely to be
aquatic creatures
than terrestrial creatures but then it
also raises another question which is
if the nutrient does so well um
in this habitat why wasn't it here in
the first place
right why did it not migrate north and
it could be
a um it could be that it is a
uh um
i'm not sure i've got one um
you know you you used to present um and
i always used this when i got to the
relevant parts in my
um in my curriculum uh a sort of a
three-pronged set of answers to why
isn't organism x and habitat y
right and um you know i'd love to do
this in such a way that we could drop
that and let people think about it and
then do it at the end but
given that we're in this conversation
broadly speaking the answers were
organism x can't exist there can't live
there
can't get there and can't compete there
so can't live there is like just unable
to function in the environment because
of say
a climatic barrier can't get there
there's some kind of a barrier to
dispersal perhaps
and that would be that's you know that's
the one i'll come back to here right
it's possible that humans needed to get
over say the sonoran desert i don't know
i have no idea right what all i would
have had to
get over but it might be that nutria
couldn't get here on their own but once
here
once here they do they clearly can live
here maybe they couldn't get here
but they clearly can also compete here
yes and so the competition
is against organisms in similar in the
similar niche
um so that three-pronged set of answers
i think is super useful like you know if
god if ecology curriculum they taught
that and only that that would be
gets you a long way gets you a very long
at least one of these things has to be
preventing any creature that isn't in
any habitat
i will also point out that our habitat
is now heavily modified
by the elimination of things like the
natural predators of many creatures
and so and fire suppression and you know
all sorts of who knows it something has
been altered but there is at least a set
of interesting questions
that follows from the observation that
these animals are now here and doing
great
and they really are doing great um even
though
climate climatically one would expect
them to be hobbled which they are
apparently not
yeah all right and final thing on this i
want to switch from the nature reserve
to our backyard and show a couple things
that are
cameras that we've set up as we attempt
to
fend off a nightly threat by
a small number of coyotes
that are persistently here we've got
three coyotes who desperately want to
eat our cats
yes they are they are failing but not
for lack of effort they are clearly
stalking our cats our dog is very eager
to take them on
i am not all that worried about her she
has in fact
tangled with coyotes physically
individually
yep i saw that uh within the last week
with
one and then saw that there were other
two the two others were waiting
like and we're out of here right yeah so
we are now quite concerned because we
have
a number of animals that it's quite
possible maddie cannot
uh fend off and in fact last night um
the we went out i always take her out
before i go to bed
and we encountered the coyotes and she
was
gonna go after them and i tried to grab
her and i um because these
these animals are stalking our cats um
we've been carrying some bear spray so
that we can send them a strong message
that will dissuade them from doing this
and i accidentally sprayed
maddie and me as i was trying to stop
her oh it's terrible
yeah that's terrible no it was really
bad um but okay so zach do you want to
show the uh incidentally our cats have
not gone outside since
since these coyotes have been right here
for like two weeks and so they're going
crazy
the coyotes um call and it isn't just
the three
here that all of the coyotes in the
surrounding area
call and they've been doing it every
night for the last several weeks except
for the last two nights where i've put a
recorder out hoping to capture it and so
anyway
they're shy somehow but zach do you want
to show the uh
they're on to us they're not shy yeah
show the first one
so this is just one of many videos ah so
what i want you to can you show that
again
what i want you to see here i noticed
last night in
the interaction uh
that maddie and i had with these coyotes
i noticed for the first time
that this animal appears to have one eye
now it may be that it's lost an eye
for those listening rather than watching
um you see the eye shine of just a
single eye
the eye shine is the reflective coating
at the back of nocturnal mammal's eyes
called it topetum lucidum
yeah so the reflective coating in the
back of the eyes actually sends
the photons through the receptive layer
twice to amplify the light
and which is why we always use headlamps
to find
nocturnal animals you shoot you you
shine a light beam close to where your
eyes are
and you're going to pick up eye shine of
any nocturnal mammals and also turns out
you know
when you're in the neotropics so many
spiders oh my goodness
but in this case um we've been watching
these animals we've seen them every
night for
weeks i've not seen a one-eyed animal
until
last night at which point i saw this
one-eyed animal and then it showed up on
our cameras which raises the possibility
that this animal got an injury that it
got a thorn in the eye and that its eye
is going to heal but it's closing its
eye
that this is a different animal that has
one eye i don't know
um but for some reason a one-eyed coyote
is now showing up
on our cameras and in person when we see
them
so that was one of the interesting
things and we have dozens of videos of
coyotes
in single multiple uh all around our
house show the other one this is another
interesting one i did not expect to see
oh this is two coyotes you can see an
eye shine in the back
of the um at the back of the video oh
yeah see there's an eye
and then this other animal is carrying
what is pretty clearly
a squirrel um and that
can you read the time stamp on that zach
yeah it's uh 805 805. so
wait that's not possible though because
it's not 2005 on april 10th yet
oh well maybe the date may be off on the
camera but in any case this is
this is clearly at night this is not
dusk this is clearly at night yeah
yeah so 805 doesn't make sense anyway
it's that's dusk here at this point
there's a question about what squirrel
12 27 okay 12 27 am yep so
just after midnight um so what squirrel
was that and how did this coyote get it
yeah right i mean squirrels are pretty
diurnal well
all except the flying squirrels boy so
we we are
big enough fans of flying squirrels and
we had some
some years near our house in olympia and
watched them
and are just you know we're animal
behaviorists we love flying squirrels
i feel like if there were flying
squirrels near here we'd we would be
likely to know
well and we do there are a couple of
fewer squirrels than any place else
we've ever lived but there are a few
squirrels and some of the trees nesting
near us and you know maybe maybe the
fact that the coyotes are taking them is
why there are fewer than
anywhere we've ever lived before part of
it um i'm certain we have flying
squirrels here
the reason so the couple of times that
we saw them
in olympia it was the same phenomenon
which was the squirrels for whatever
reason
were in a battle with each other which
caused them to vocalize
the thing about flying squirrels is when
they don't vocalize they can fly they're
not
uncommon but when they fly over your
head you're very unlikely to know that
it happens they fly
yeah from a branch to a tree trunk so
just to be clear they're not actually
flying they don't have powered flight
they can't get left unless they catch a
thermal between trees which is pretty
unlikely
yeah i mean i always i wonder about you
know climbing a tree to power your
flight seems to me like
powered flight but it seems like a
semantic argument
it is but so is the argument that they
don't fly but anyway never mind they
they glide flying over your head they're
gliding over your head
they glide but they have a very
impressive glide ratio they can go a
long distance
and their landings are perfectly silent
because they're on the tree trunk rather
than in the bridge
they land vertically right yeah they
land on the tree trunk
um so it's not like you you know with
monkeys you typically hear the
leaves wrestling when the animal moves
before you you know sometimes a long
time before you figure out where the
animal is you know there's something
over there and it's got to be of a
certain size in this case actually i
think
i'm not positive but i think actually
the vertical grasping and leaping
that is characteristic of the arboreal
locomotion
of the group of lemurs called the
indriads the
shafox and the injury are also somewhat
quieter
than the um than the leaping around in
trees of say neotropical monkeys because
they're doing this thing but i used to
um demonstrate for students but i'm not
going to get up and do it here now
um that is really it's throwing
themselves from vertical bowl from
vertical tree to vertical tree
um and they land sort of in this
position um that it is a bit quieter
because
in part because they're not interfacing
with foliage right they're just
interfacing shaking of the foliage is
the thing that gives animals away
so anyway i know that we have flying
squirrels i don't think that was a
flying squirrel i think the tail was too
fat
um i didn't see the light under body
underbelly
um so anyway i think that was a diurnal
squirrel which raises the question of
how a coyote
is coming up with a diurnal squirrel at
12 30 at night
is it finding them it can't climb it's a
coyote
yeah so yeah so we've instantly we've
gotten a tiny bit of pushback in the
past
like of course dogs can climb my grandma
i had a dog that could climb famously
um but you know canids um compared to
felids actually just can't and again
sorry for the people just listening but
uh this this action of pronation uh is
limited for canid so cats are great at
this
and and that ability to basically move
your radius around your ulna
is what allows climbing um and so if
you're limited in this position if you
cannot pronate because your radius and
ulna are effectively locked
in in position much more so than they
are and say the the felids
um then your climbing is going to be
very much restricted because you because
you cannot grasp
so in light of all that there's some
mystery here
how did this coyote end up with a dire
seemingly a diurnal squirrel which
presumably
uh nests high in a tree for exactly this
reason
right so anyway i think that probably we
are going to be unable to answer this
question
be interesting if somebody who was
expert on coyotes had some sense
about whether this was a fluke could be
an animal that you know
died and it was found fresh and the
coyote didn't
turn up its nose at the already dead
animal it's possible
but i think it's unlikely i also will
say though that i am
uh now spurred to try to use
these game cameras to find flying
squirrels
so i'm gonna see if we can't nail down
our flying squirrels and document their
presence here you don't want to actually
nail them down no no no i
was a figure of speech strictly i'm uh
i'm a liberal i
i resonate with the flying squirrels i
don't want to see them nailed to
anything
excellent yeah i'm glad we agree on that
all right um are we there yep i think we
are okay
um so uh
apropos uh the movement that is
happening in many
uh many state legislatures in the united
states right now
to limit the ability of children to
medically and surgically transition
and specifically um the state of
arkansas was the first
to to do to do this a couple of weeks
ago
and the aclu and what is becoming its
generic
knee-jerk frankly uninvestigated stance
um said you know trans youth will be
denied healthcare
and it made it seem like all healthcare
like if you show up with a broken arm
and you're trans
and you're 16 you would not get your arm
set
which of course is not true and so i
mocked the aclu as has become the thing
that i do
on twitter by rephrasing their
what they said accurately and actually
maybe i'll just
show this or read this what i said was
um
here actually the aclu said breaking
arkansas has become the first state to
ban health care for trans youth i quote
tweeted them and said breaking arkansas
has become the first state to ban gender
transition procedures in people under 18
and the aclu has become the first
organization to wildly misrepresent what
has happened
someone um and you don't need to show
this sack but someone with a fancy phd
and a lab of their own
said quote tweeting me and thinking i
think that he had schooled me
uh gender dysphoria can start around
seven years old and includes a link and
in fact includes three links
um and i could i could tear all of them
apart but i'm just going to talk about
one of them and what it led me to to
think about here
um so the one the the first paper
um that he links to excuse me
is this one you can just show this
quickly this is a research letter
in um jama network open
published last year by several authors
called age at first experience of gender
dysphoria among transgender adults
seeking gender affirming surgery
okay so that's it and
i looked through it and it does indeed
find assuming that it's doing an
accurate job of describing what what it
was looking at that some people who
transition later in life start saying
that they are trans at a very young age
um okay yeah that's i believe that
um i mean i would i would be shocked if
that weren't true in fact
in fact it has to be it has to be true
right
so the missing piece of the research
though the idea that that research
is in any way a rebuttal to my
implied claim and what i and what i
tweeted and i'm going to talk explicitly
about what my implied claim is here
the thing that is missing from that as
an argument against giving medical and
surgical intervention
to children is how many children who do
not later transition
say the same thing and we in fact
have probably no way of knowing that i
would love those data i would
love to know and you know we would
basically have to survey
um widely across all children
and ask parents you know did your child
ever say something like i'm a boy or i'm
a girl
and it wasn't their natal sex or did
they dress up in mom you know
you do find the boy in mom's heels one
day um
and you know any number of sort of
gender non-conforming things that are
now taken as evidence of
of transness and absent that
absent knowing how many people and i
will posit that i am
certain but i do not have the data and i
don't think it's possible to get the
data again
that um a much larger number of children
of course make such claims because
make-believe and playing with identity
and exploration is exactly what
childhood is about
so the fact that some people who do
later transition
make claims early on is not evidence
that we need to be supporting
their transitions medically and
surgically and here's
why um i would ask which era does
society prefer
that we make should we intervene in an
early age with experimental and known to
be unsafe medical and surgical
interventions such that a large number
of
non-trans adults are mutilated both
physically and mentally for life
or should we fail to intervene at an
early age with experimental and known to
be unsafe medical and surgical
interventions such that a tiny number of
actual trans adults come to be a
slightly less good fit for their
internally perceived
gender so we can use the language of
statistics here i think quite usefully
and some people will actually be better
able to make sense of the landscape this
way and
certainly people like this this
professor
um who thought that he had made a uh a
killing blow
at my argument should be able to do this
kind of logic
this is going to be the language of null
and alternative hypotheses and the kinds
of errors that can result that is to say
type 1 and type 2 errors so the null
hypothesis which is the
also called the default hypothesis in
this case is that you are not trans
that if you are a child the null
hypothesis is that you're not trans the
alternative hypothesis is that you are
why is the null hypothesis that you're
not
oh 500 million years of uninterrupted
sexual reproduction in human history and
overwhelming evidence that a deeply felt
disconnect between your actual sex to
perceived sex is extraordinarily rare
we have said on this podcast and
elsewhere many many times that we
understand trans to be real
and exceedingly rare and that a majority
of what is going on right now in the
names
in the name of trans rights is not
actually about actual
transness so the null hypothesis is
you're not trans type 1 errors when they
occur
are that you have rejected the null
hypothesis even though it is true also
known as a false positive
in this case in the case that i'm
talking about here you reject
um a type one error would be assuming
that you are trans even though you're
not
and the societal ramification of such a
type one error
would be encouraging transition even for
those who do not turn out to warrant it
or want it
compare that to a type 2 error
which involves rejecting the alternative
hypothesis even though it
is true also known as a false negative
okay in this case the one that we're
talking about right here
a type two error would be assuming that
you are not trans even though you in
fact
are and the societal ramification would
be again preventing people who do turn
out to be trans
uh from transitioning early in life so
given
given that we've got two types of errors
type one errors and type two errors in
this landscape
of people who aren't trans and people
who are trans and we have childhood and
a long period of development and how can
you know early on and what should you do
given that the background rate of trans
people is exceedingly low
i think actually it is our human
societal responsibility to minimize
type 1 errors in this case to drive to
as close to zero the number of healthy
children harmed with medical and
surgical intervention
for two broad reasons the sheer numbers
of people who are going to be harmed
by medical and surgical intervention um
is so much larger um than
those who are harmed by failing to
surgically or medically intervene fully
aside from whether or not the medical or
surgical intervention itself is
is a healthy thing to do but just
looking at the numbers of people who are
and are not trans the
number of people who will be harmed by
intervention when it was not called for
is
so much higher and secondly intervention
and
to you know to this to the later point
intervention in this functional
ancient system when no demonstration of
the safety of that intervention
has been made goes against all that at
least i understand to be
moral and right and in fact just
for me this is in fact a matter of
justice and i think that in fact
reframing
trying trying to get the narrative back
and reframing some of these issues is
actually
you know who is on the side of social
justice for populations like children
and you know and and women is is those
of us who are saying you are redefining
things and you are misunderstanding
statistics and you have taken
a you know a radically deficient data
set to try to make a point in which you
are actively harming people whom you
have no right to harm
not only people that you have no right
to harm but we are talking about a
population of
kids who show some sign of
dysphoria right that group
presumably includes some trans people
people who will
persist in their dysphoria and it
includes presumably many people
who whose dysphoria will clear up we
know that that's a common pattern
so the point is actually that group
kids with dysphoria need protection from
medicine that would surgically alter
them thereby eliminating their
potential to reproduce as adults
risking their sexual functionality as
adults
and so the point is if you are
interested in protecting
kids with gender dysphoria it is
incumbent on you
not to provide this surgery in light of
the fact
that um that many of those kids will not
grow up to be trans adults and so by
doing the study in such a way that you
are looking through the lens of
of those people who were trans as adults
many of them
believed they had just gender dysphoria
as children
you are looking at the wrong the wrong
data set as you point out exactly
and um it's simply there's no
justification for policy
even those who ultimately go on to
be trans as adults cannot have known
that their gender dysphoria would be
permanent
as children and in light of that that
group
gender dysphoric kids needs protection
so that they have the full range of
options when they grow up
exactly and you know true gender
dysphoria
is is a tiny subset of those people who
are gendered on
non-conforming um and gender
non-conforming kids
is a subset of people of children who
are just exploring identity
right and um and you know i would hope
that actually all children are exploring
identity i would hope
that that is uh you know perfect that
sample is a perfect match for the
population that is children
some children aren't able to or maybe
they just don't explore you know
and certainly a lot of kids don't
explore over in gender identity space
um it's not inherently interesting um to
everyone but
the idea that um all you have to have
done
is to be different from
the societal norms frankly from the
1950s right
to in some cases be pushed
into something that will permanently
alter so much about your life
is should be criminal and in fact what
we are seeing are these you know
once once necessary
powerhouse organizations like the aclu
who are turning this on its head
and who are defending the you know the
right and therefore this sort of this
you know the steamrolling
of of modifying children for permanently
because really you know increasingly now
we're finally seeing but you know even
as recently as a couple years ago people
were still saying well
you know there's no there's there's no
harm just you know block them just you
know put them on puberty blockers it'll
be fine
and then that allow them to figure it
out it's like well hey if you're on
puberty blockers nothing about your
development is now normal there's no
figuring things out as if things weren't
going along normally at this point
but certainly certainly you're going to
have effects
like and we already we've gone through
all of these but you know physical
mental psychological effects fertility
effects you know all you know sexual
function effects all of these things
so um i don't know uh if you're where
you were headed with this but i do want
to make clear why you and i
both think it is inevitable that you
will have
some fraction of trans adults
who experience gender dysphoria as kids
and why
therefore we need to be very careful to
draw any conclusion at
all from the fact of that group existing
right
so in other words it it seems important
well if there are people who know that
they're trans when they're young then
why not
you know get them on the road to
whatever
adult role they're going to play as
quickly as possible but here's the
problem
even if you're
gender conforming or non-conformity
as a child and that same parameter as an
adult were completely independent of
each other
100 independent some
small fraction of people would flip the
coin the same
unusual way twice and so it is
inevitable that you will have a group of
adults
given that there are trans adults and
given that there are gender uh
their dysphoric kids some number of
people
will have been both even if there were
no implications whatsoever
and the fact is there probably is some
implication
of your dysphoria as a child and
dysphoria as an adult
so of course there is i mean like i i
get your point and i think it's you know
it's
it's true but i think like of course
it's going to be a core
of course if you are a trans adult you
are more likely
um to have shown dysphoria as as a child
but
um you know dysphoria and gender
non-conformity
are im imprecisely and often
inaccurately assigned
they are conflated and there will be
plenty of people with one or both
who do not turn into being trans people
as adults
right um totally agree the reason i'm
highlighting this is that the there's a
monty hall
problem buried in here which is
going to result in people upon the
discovery that some people apparently
know from a very early age that they're
trans when that's not really what they
know they're dysphoric as young people
and it turns out that they
at the point that they are in a position
to judge are trans
um but it does not have any
implication whatsoever for how we should
treat those young people
because it isn't as as long as the
category
of people who were dysphoric and don't
go on to be trans as adults
is a sizable fraction they deserve
protection and you
cannot act especially in light of the
fact that even if
transition is more successful if you
start
early right it is still successful
enough if somebody upon
you know reaching 18 or 20 years of age
says yep
i'm trans at that point right they still
have options
and so protecting kids from permanent
modifications as you point out even the
hormone even the
puberty blockers are permanent
modifications because of the way they
inter
interface with development is it has to
be prevented
yep all right so um what may not appear
at first to be related but the next
thing we want to talk about i feel like
is exactly you know demonstrates sort of
the coherence of our
world view with this evolutionary lens
which is that um
the fda that is the federal drug
the food and drug administration here in
the u.s
has approved a new drug to treat adhd
which is a
tension deficit and hyperactivity
disorder
so let me just show first
um the this is the diagnostic criteria
for adhd
okay um
and actually the hyperactive impulsive
type diagnosis because that's what we're
talking about squirms when seated or
fidgets with feet and hands
marked restlessness that is difficult
difficult to control
appears to be driven by a motor or is
often on the go
lacks ability to play and engage in
leisure activities in a quiet manner
incapable of staying seated in class
overly talkative
and it goes on um
when we were teaching i occasionally
probably at least
once every quarter that i had a new
group of students
sometimes more than that i'd have some
very smart
young male student
come to me having failed to turn
something in on time
and ashamed what explained to me that he
had adhd
and i started to say to these smart
young men
of course that's the diagnosis you're a
smart young man
like this be this became this be it
became predictable
and that does not mean just and i
actually feel like this is a part this
is a really good map
for for trans like i believe that there
is something
at the edges um that is real and
that there are people who actually will
benefit from some kind of intervention i
don't know that that intervention exists
yet for adhd i don't think it's this new
drug and i don't think it's the old
drugs and all of that
but i do think that there is a real
thing and
like with trans um and possibly for some
of the very same profit motive reasons
by the pharmaceuticals it has become
this
huge thing in which the vast majority of
parents who think that they are only
caring for their children
are trying to take care of their
children
and it certainly makes their jobs easier
and the teacher's job's easier if
instead
of a classroom in which a quarter of the
kids are bouncing off the walls and
and having a hard time sitting down when
they're told to they're now basically
drugged into quiescence
well that does make your job easier
doesn't it but it also means you've
drugged your children
and indeed from the cdc i found another
line
under the hyperactivity variant which
just
cracked me up um this is one of the
diagnostic criteria from the dsm for
adhd
often leaves seat in situations
remaining when remaining seated is
expected
expected right the problem is clearly
with the child who's driven to get out
of their seat
exactly so i again i'm just
because this came up on on twitter this
week
um i was directed to this article um
that got put out um and you can put it
on the screen if you like
zack i said hey look new drugs to fix
broken children
maybe the environment in which so many
children find themselves
oh sorry maybe the environment in which
so many children find themselves a bad
fit could be altered rather than
altering the children
to fit the environment and
there is a lot of good positive reaction
to that and some people who think i'm
satan
right the idea that i am against
drugging children and instead think that
maybe
we should create school environments
that are a better fit for all of our
children and not just
the um smart and middlingly smart girls
which frankly is what school is mostly a
pretty good fit for at the moment
um is apparently a bridge too far
well uh the perverse incentives here are
uh
many and i have no doubt that many
well-intentioned people have ended up
um allowing their children to be
drugged and the cognitive dissonance
required
cannot withstand the scrutiny of someone
who points out that a child getting out
of their seat
is hardly an indication of a disorder
especially in light of the fact that
seats themselves
are now the root of many a disorder that
we now recognize these are not
healthy objects and right um
what's going on the same society that is
celebrating standing desks right is
drugging children people who don't
keep their butts inside exactly there's
something off um
so i would also say that the system we
have built
is so clearly guaranteed to produce an
outcome where i agree i don't know
whether adhd
is real but i suspect that it is i know
for sure i would have been diagnosed
with it
if um it had been a thing when i was a
kid
um but i you know
i think we've got a novelty problem
which is to say
uh all right
yeah it's all it's all good wow that's
some serious cat chaos
right a cat quake um
thanks zack the uh
as i was saying the um
they're going bonkers from being locked
inside for two weeks let's imagine for a
second that they're
you know in the fantastically complex
series of events that have to unfold in
order for development to work out
properly
there's something that causes a certain
a small number of children to be
hyperactive
and not be able to focus on something
right
then there is a question of okay what do
we do about this
tiny percentage of children and the
answer is oh well we've got a lot of
drugs we can try and then it turns out
that drugs that have really powerful
effects
many of them have some interaction with
this because of course they would
right and so you find some drug like
speed that happens to do
something with these kids that actually
paradoxically as many things
as many pharmaceuticals work with
children it you know calms them
right it's effectively functioning as
some kind of sedative
right and then what happens next okay
you say well this is the drug that
treats that as if it was a specific
interaction rather than just something
that has massive effects across the
brain
one of which happens to look positive
especially in light of the
uh jerry-rigged system in which the drug
companies
test whether or not something has a
positive effect it's not a tight
hypothesis driven scientist
no it's uh it's not hypothesis driven if
you know what i mean
um but then the question is okay
once you've concluded through whatever
you know
uh it's effectively a kind of idea
laundering not of the typical kind but
idea laundering where you make some drug
out to be the solution to some problem
that you vaguely understand or at least
can recognize
then the question is okay how many kids
might have it
and what do you think the drug company's
desired answer for that
is i think it's a lot it's a lot it's a
really large number this is
wildly undone you don't want your child
to be sick do you right oh what do we
have to do well you know maybe
you know johnny doesn't appear to have
uh adhd but maybe he's got adhd
type b you know this kind of right
so you just did he stand up when you
didn't want him to stand up
i saw him standing i did yeah when he
was sharpening his pencil
right yeah that's what he says right
before he sharpened his pencil he
got out of his seat which is one of the
diagnostic characteristics
yeah that johnny he uh he's clearly an
adhd type
we can fix them though we can fix them
right good we'll fix them good
so one of this just this article that i
linked to in that tweet
um says quote and i have no idea how to
pronounce this
kilbri with a q is apparently the name
of the new drug
um and it's being lauded as not speed
right like
not speed to treat your adhd kid
kelbridge developed by supernus
pharmaceuticals of rockville maryland
carries a warning of potential for
suicidal thoughts and behavior which
occurred in fewer than one percent of
volunteers and studies of the drug
short-term studies of the drug in which
we're being told that these children are
going to be on it for
many many years so right one percent is
low and i'm sorry and you know less than
one percent i don't know what the number
is i couldn't i couldn't track it down
but
um you're creating suicidal ideation in
a population that had none
i'm sorry that's unacceptable it's
unacceptable that's unacceptable
one percent because they get out of
their [ __ ] seats right one percent is
a huge number
right so yeah yes it says fewer fewer
but the point is
you know it's not fewer than one in a
thousand right
this is a large number as you point out
it's a large number in a short period so
does that mean that as you put people on
this long term you're going to cycle all
of them through suicidal ideation who
knows
which which we know happens with many of
the other drugs
um neuroleptics and anti-depression meds
that are on the market already and this
is more
this is closer to that class of drugs
biochemically than it is to speed and
you know you you alluded to this uh in
your introduction to this topic
but there is a chronic condition
undiagnosed in my opinion in which
society
takes all of the problems that we are
causing by inflicting novelty on people
and then falsely diagnoses the person as
disordered
and then seeks to treat them for profit
right it's like
you know it's a racket and um it's not
to say that disorders don't exist they
clearly do and of course they exist at a
larger
a higher rate than they would otherwise
because people do grow up in an
environment that is chemically socially
in every other way
uh novel we probably we probably do
benefit far more from drugs
than would our ancestors have had they
been available because we have created
so many problems with our environment
yeah yeah your ancestors because they
were a good match for their environment
would almost
never have benefited from drugs you know
you've got the occasional circumstance
of somebody getting an
infected um limb where an antibiotic
might
might help them or something but well
you know not
you know we don't need to straw man
western medicine right because it does
it it does it plenty well itself but
like um as we have said here and
elsewhere for
decades we have long viewed antibiotics
and vaccines and surgery as the three
major triumphs of western medicine
and all of them are overused
and that doesn't mean they're
anti-antibiotic or anti-vaxxers or
anti-surgery except in some situations
of course because there's some
situations that don't call for
antibiotics
or vaccines or surgery and there are a
lot of things that would benefit from a
different approach entirely
i am anti the pretense of safety
right the fact is all of these things
have dangerous just as
we know that every single drug has a
lethal dose
they're all toxic they have to be in
order to function right for them to be
physiologically
interactive means that there is a dose
at which you
um are doing harm so
the recognition that all of these things
are unsafe and instead of having
a stupid debate over whether or not
they're safe having a debate about how
unsafe are they and therefore when is it
worth taking that risk and when is it
not
would be well well worth it and what and
about the risk and then about the the
benefit like you know who
what percentage of people are actually
getting what
level of benefit when they take this
drug and what percentage of people who
take this drug
are actually suffering costs and what is
the level of cost
and um with with something like this
or you know with something with a lot of
drugs
that actually should be an entirely
individual decision yeah
vaccines is trickier vaccines is
trickier
um but you know even just our family has
so many stories in which we have come to
ultimately understand that we were
exposed to risk we didn't know about
from the orthodontia that i had as a kid
your
uh achilles uh tendon repair
uh my hair so much as the rupture that
really got to me well that's the thing
both the rupture and the ripple no the
surgical repair has
it still plagues me um what is it seven
six years later and it turns out that
this is something that will heal on its
own without surgery
right which was something we did not
understand fully at the time yeah to be
explored more
later in my case it turns out not only
was it a complete rupture but even the
sheath
in which the achilles tendon runs was
ruptured so
it's not actually 100 clear in my case
that it would have healed like when the
sheath remains
but the achilles is totally ruptured it
it repairs but without the sheath to
guide it it's not clear what would
happen
yeah all right well we'll return to it
another time but uh
even just for a small family to have at
least
four instances in which um yatrogenic
harm that is to say medically induced
uh harm is evident uh because of the
enthusiasm of doctors and dentists well
i don't think we spelled out that with
regard to
the achilles rupture in the first place
it was probably it was almost certainly
affected by and maybe largely driven by
the fact that i had taken a fair bit of
cipro
uh when we were doing a lot of field
work both together and independently
um in our 20s and cipro and the entire
class i don't remember what that
that class that drug class name is right
now um
of drugs is now known to cause soft
tissue specifically ligament tendon
damage yep
but yep no indication then no just take
cipro if you you know you need to get on
a bus for 12 hours and you got
gi stuff you need to take zip bro yep
uh all right so um
this next one so we got three more
topics here um
this next one is is brief but i actually
think it sort of wraps up this
you know talking about medically um
medically intervening uh with children
who declare themselves trans medically
intervening
with children who have been diagnosed
with adhd
and here we go this isn't about medical
intervention but um
the organization let grow which was
founded and i think is still run by
our friend the amazing lenore skinesi
tweeted about this paper
which is not showing up hold on i will
find it on
[Music]
i will try to find it and i don't
okay well uh princeton dropped me out so
i do not have
that paper up anymore a paper called um
children persist less when adults take
over published in child development just
published now and i will put a link up
although
um it looks like you'll need to do some
fancy work behind the scenes to get it
without university
um just to just to say what they've
found it's pretty good paper it's
it's uh it's social science and they do
three sub separate sets of experiments
and uh this paragraph from the
discussion
um aptly summarizes what they've done or
what they've found
we found that when adults take over and
solve hard problems for children
children persist less first we showed
that parental taking over negatively
relates to parent report of child
persistence
yeah that's not so interesting right
then the second two experiments they do
in an experimental study we demonstrated
that taking over causes children to
persist less on a subsequent difficult
task
and finally in a second experimental
study we found that changing the
language and context of taking over
slightly but not significantly
ameliorated the negative impact of
taking over on children's persistence
and in the following paragraph they say
our findings suggest that it may be
easier to demotivate children
than to motivate them which i thought
that was sort of the crux and that we
can you know you haven't read the paper
but i don't think
i don't think you need to basically what
it says and what lenore says
in tweeting this leonardo skanacy it's
like well you know duh this should be
obvious
but so much of modern parenting style is
about intervening it's about getting in
the way of normal childhood and normal
childhood development and in this case
it's not about drugging it's just about
a parent
watching a kid struggle in a small way
with like a puzzle or a task
and in those cases where the parent is
like let me just do it for you
or let's just forget to show you how to
do it let me show you how to do it let
me do it for you let's just forget about
it and move on to something else all of
those
are you know are demonstrably
resulting in children being less likely
to persist in later tasks that are hard
they become less um less interested in
difficulty
yeah and uh as we
both discovered and um thought quite a
bit about as in our teaching lives
the failure of motivation is the key
factor in the failure of education right
a a child who comes to understand
that a problem can be solved and that
being
dogged in pursuing the solution results
in ultimately getting there in other
words a relationship with the failure
that comes
along with progress that is healthy
is the key thing and even for students
who appear to be doing very well in
school and therefore you would expect to
succeed
when they get out into the world if what
they have learned to do
is to succeed in order to please the
person at the front of the room
then at the point you remove the person
at the front of the room the person does
not know how
to accomplish anything and these things
are devastating
if there's no carrot what am i doing
right and it doesn't even add up that
way
it's like the whole idea i guess the
point is you've got
it's like a almost a military mindset
right where
the soldier might be very good at doing
what they do but they do it because
somebody has ordered them
that's the hill you're going to take and
to the extent that that's the
educational model
then the point is okay well this may be
great for producing
people who will do what their boss tells
them to do but it's not great
for teaching people how to innovate and
solve their own problems or even
recognize their own problems again it
probably
makes the educational environment easier
to deal with right especially if you've
got some unruly kids some people
who are unmedicated adhd types right
they're more likely if they are trained
to be motivated by the teacher's
approval
or by being you know being given a task
and
um you know having it be pretty easy
and knowing that you'll be moved on to
the next task and you'll get another
star stamped on your forehead as a
result
those you know those classrooms are
certainly easier to navigate
but they don't produce independent
autonomous thinkers with
agency nor i think what we are seeing in
the world
nor do they produce people with
particular amount of compassion or
respect for people who don't look like
them
yeah like that that that is actually
what we are seeing is that the people
who are yelling loudest
over in wokeville are actually the least
compassionate the least respectful of
people who don't sound just like them
yeah i think this is exactly uh right
and i think i was
going to draw the same analogy for a
different reason which just has to do
with the fact that we are
interrupting all sorts of processes
that are about figuring out how to
navigate the world
right by telling people oh you're having
trouble navigating the world that's
because the world is [ __ ] up
right now the world is [ __ ] up but
when you tell people the reason that
you're having a problem
is because the world is [ __ ] up and
therefore it relieves all of the burden
on you to figure out how to interact
with the world
then you don't learn how to interact
with the world what you do is you demand
that the world be bent
to fit you and that is not viable
the fact is no matter how bad a world
you've been born into
right you absolutely want to figure out
how to make the best use of it no matter
how
unfair it is that you were exposed to
that world and maybe other people aren't
exposed to that same level of
dysfunction nonetheless
it is absolutely clear that your best
investment is figuring out how to make
the best
use of the world as you find it and then
demand that it be fixed but don't demand
that it be fixed
instead of figuring out what to do about
how to interact with that world because
you're not going to get anywhere if
you're waiting for you know
effectively utopia which is what so much
of this is about right we we're we're
not going to do anything
until you've fixed every last ounce of
every problem that we've named
and it's like well that world isn't
coming nor nor could it exist it's not a
plausible world even
yes so um you're harming yourself by
um you know by stamping you you know
effectively we've got a generation
that's stamping its feet
you know in the aisles of the market
demanding stuff
right and uh well it's a disaster
as as nancy romellman has said many
times uh they have demonstrated a clear
ability to break things
um but we are still waiting on a
demonstration of their ability to make
things
yeah that's uh an excellent way to put
it
all right well we've got two more topics
here uh brett you want to talk about
um what is going on and i know almost
nothing about this
um so you are going to take the lead on
yeah yes so i just wanted to point out
and i think zach i sent you a
link this is just one of many places um
that uh this show this is a newsweek
article
um describing what has gone on jordan
peterson discovered
can you show it on the big screen to
zach since i haven't seen this yet and i
can't read it there
um so jordan peterson
discovered this week that he
was clearly i would say being parodied
by tonahisi coates
in captain america effectively
peterson's 12 rules for life has been
changed to
10 rules for life and
peterson himself is being analogized to
a
arch villain red skull
who has nazi overtones and
this is noteworthy for a number of
reasons right
um it's literal villainizing
right peterson actually literally right
literally being villainized here and i
would say
you know jordan is a friend he
deserves nothing less than to be
villainized he may be wrong about things
though i would say it is incumbent on
anyone who says he is
to point out in what way he's wrong but
being wrong and being a villain
are two very different things and uh
i have seen peterson interact
up close with his many many fans who
come up to him
you know he could have lines out the
door of people coming up saying you
changed my life you helped me find
direction you helped me get myself out
of a hole that i was in
increase my capacity all of these things
are things that are commonly being said
to him so
the idea of turning him into literally a
cartoon villain
is so insane uh as to be absurd but it's
grotesque
the other reason that i wanted to
mention this
is that we are constantly asked why
we only supposedly interact with people
who agree with us supposedly about
things like wokism
and i don't think this is true but
it is true that we interact mostly with
people who agree with us on this and
part of the problem is it's very hard
this topic
yes it's very hard to find people on the
supposed other side of this topic
who can be partnered with enough to even
have a reasonable discussion
and so from my part i have been saying
for quite
some time that i find tanahisi coats to
be a very
different sort of person than ibrahim
kendy
or robin deangelo or any of these other
folks
we as a family read between the world
and me
back in um would have been fall 2016
right before the school year started i
read it aloud to
the to us i certainly got a lot out of
it
i thought it didn't have exactly my
perspective but i learned
about uh coates perspective and i
believed it was a valid and valuable
book and i have said so
publicly and so therefore coats exists
in a separate category to me somebody
who could be productively interacted
with
and somebody who brings something to the
table that i think is worthwhile and so
uh in any case some of the people you
know uh um
john mcwhirter has given coats a very
hard time
as has glenn lowry but in any case it
sort of feels like coates was
the person for to
to whom we could address critique and
receive critique from
but what are we to do when the
reasonable person on the other side of
the discussion
starts villainizing somebody literally
villainizing them
as some sort of a nazi-esque uh
you know figure there's just nothing to
do
right so in any case i don't know i'm
curious what the 10 rules for life that
red skull is espousing are i'm wondering
if
you know you know one of the more famous
ones from 12 rules for life because i
read it
i i thought it was a powerful book and
you know it wasn't
it was i wasn't the target audience for
it and i think and actually i think
katie herzog said this
um first but i had the sense of like
okay i don't
need this in the way that i know a lot
of people need it and i didn't learn as
much as many people did from it
therefore
but i see its value and i was i was
deeply touched by it
and i did learn some things as well but
you know one of the one of the rules in
the original 12 rules and of course he's
got another book out now with 12 more
uh was when you see a cat on the street
pet it
i'm just i'm wondering if there's a a
modification of that in here
i don't think so i think that one when
you see a cat on the street feed it to a
coyote carefully excluded
uh from this portrayal yeah um
yeah i mean what i did see was the
suggestion
that uh the jordanian
red skull character was leading young
men to believe that everyone was against
them and that they needed to rise
up that kind of thing which oddly is
almost exactly
like that yeah uh with what jordan's
message
actually is jordan's cleaning up your
room right jordan's message is about
um taking responsibility for your
position in the world
and not concentrating heavily on uh
other people get you know don't compare
yourself to them compare yourself to who
you were yesterday that kind of
thing and so anyway deeply unfair
to do this to to jordan who i must say
um
despite uh significant differences in
viewpoint i find him unendingly decent
absolutely right um so anyway
what a terrible thing to to do this and
frankly
um i do think you owe
jordan an apology coats and i
can't it's hard to imagine in light of
having released this that you're going
to deliver that apology but um
you know what possessed you to do this
right
all right that's about all i've got on
that topic
okay um you
so for our final topic today uh maybe
sunlight really is the best disinfectant
and i don't know much more than you
sent me a link to this article
zachary sunlight inactivates coronavirus
eight times faster than predicted
we need to know why and that links to
this paper uvb radiation alone may not
explain sunlight and activation of saris
cov2
um a paper that came out actually in
february of of this year that finds
basically the theoretical underpinnings
for why
um why it was thought that sars kobe 2
was not transmitting
as i guess was not transmitting and was
not there for manifesting as kovit and
people who were outdoors was
largely based on a model around uvc i
think
deactivating um deactivating the virus
but um
the empirical evidence that's come in
since those early theoretical
predictions
says actually no there's got to be a lot
more going on this virus is just
unable to persist out in sunlight for
very long at all
and um you know we're not gonna we're
not gonna go inside baseball here on on
you know all of the reasons all of the
disconnects um but
it's fabulous news like there is not a
variant yet
that we have heard of sorry's kobe 2 um
for which this is not true that is to
say which does
not um deactivate in sunlight which
means that the advice that we've been
giving from the very beginning
go outside spend time outside and you
know and you know do
you do not need to wear a mask outside
unless you're jammed together
um holds and is you know is even it's
important for mental health it's
important for physical health it's
important at just about every level
possible
yes and uh so i want to recap a little
bit about what we've
said a sarsko v2
does not appear to transmit outdoors
that could be a purely
uv light or sunlight more generally
based phenomenon but it isn't it doesn't
appear to transmit outdoors at night
either
right so that's really important what
that means is that you've got
at least two mechanisms and that
what it results in is at least for the
time being that we have
a loophole in the constraints that come
from sars kobe 2 especially when the
weather is hospitable and meeting
outdoors as possible
and we should be taking full advantage
of that you wanted to say something
uh well hold on um
i mean one obvious second explanation
and i suspect it will be
more than two is that it is well
understood that this like
i don't know maybe all but certainly
many and i think most
uh viruses and other pathogens are
effectively density dependent
and so outside where there is airflow
and where you're constantly blowing away
boundary layers
and you know the virus is you know
heading up into the atmosphere as
opposed to staying in the room where you
are
is going to be effective at effectively
dispersing
the virus well we know this to be the
case the question is is
that the mechanism that makes uh night
safe
outdoors um it is unlikely that that is
completely the explanation
i said i said one one clear hypothesis
that i would say i can't imagine that
this isn't true and i just wanted to
name the two that we
definitely know are true right volume
and airflow
reduces the density of particles that
one interacts with and that that has
a highly protective effect and we know
that
uv light disables the virus and maybe
sunlight does so more generally than
just its uv component
why is an interesting question whether
this interacts with the question of
where
sarsko v2 came from if it was laboratory
in origin
obviously laboratories are not drenched
in sunlight they are drenched in
artificial light
of course the fact that the virus
ultimately comes from bats
whether it was modified in the lab or
not does suggest it would not interact
terribly frequently in daylight as bats
are all nocturnal so anyway there's a
lot of questions that could be
uh addressed but um a
could it evolve to be transmitted
outdoors it could so we should be
cautious outdoors though not overly so
um but for the moment it is apparently
the answer to
how to keep things functional um
during a time when you can't afford to
do certain normal things like
uh you know go to a concert um so
in any case it's uh it is an important
finding
and it is important for us to continue
to track whether or not that changes but
the fact that no variant yet
has um has figured out how to transmit
outdoors is great news
it sure is yeah um
okay before we go into end of you know
sign off announcements uh you want to
show the thumbnail that you chose for
this week which is um
from a little photo essay that you were
working on yesterday perhaps yes well
i'm
trying to get decent pictures of these
uh
these here animals including our epic
tabby fairfax here
so this is a little bit um a little bit
confusing because i keep saying
our cats haven't been outside in two
weeks um we
specifically the two of us let them
outside just um
right outside our house with us on them
the whole time
because they were crying it was such a
beautiful day and they were crying
crying crying to come out
so yeah um and you know and we wouldn't
our tesla our 10 year old cat the black
cat kept wanting to
wander off and i scooped him up four
times and finally was like dude you're
not listening to the rules
and as soon as we scooped them all up we
saw coyote
they were watching they're watching and
of course we run the risk of
uh renewing the smells that they leave
outdoors and that could reinvigorate the
coyotes
in tesla's case his failure to listen to
the rules i'm fairly certain
is indicative of adhd
type c cat variety
and i have no doubt that there are
pharmaceuticals
available to treat his condition so um i
did actually
um get him high on catnap recently as
you know
and uh fairfax the epic tabby who was
just on screen was somehow not
aware of this and so tesla and uh
and moxie or their cat enjoyed their
little foray into
cat high and um i guess they told
fairfax about it though because
uh a couple of nights later fairfax had
figured out how to break into the
cabinet and got him and all of his
friends high and they were rolling
around
um being completely stoned for the
evening yes um
it's a constant battle to um to keep
that cat out of the drugs
keep the cat out of the drugs yes all
right
all right so we are going to take a
15-minute break uh for those of you
watching and then go to the live q a
answering questions you've posed during
the super chat uh
we did a practice run of our super chat
replacement system this last week and
we'll do one or two more before
going live so we're still doing super
chat uh one thing i forgot to mention is
i
i had a wonderful conversation with
bridget fedesy this week um
and that's up on watkins welcome we
talked a lot about vaccine passports
among other things something that we
have not really talked about on air so
um go look for that if you're interested
in that conversation
uh do consider joining us at either of
our patreons
you get a free monthly two-hour q a
live q a with us at my patreon and um
brett has conversations at his as well
the next one
at the highest dollar amount is tomorrow
morning actually from 9 to 11 pacific
time that is evolution focused
evolution focused please send any
questions to darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com as well as logistical
questions like how do i do this
um yeah maybe that's it we've got a
great clips channel
it's continuing to turn out clips and if
there's anything that you really want
clipped
consider emailing again
darkrest.moderator gmail.com and they
will
forward that to the awesome person who
makes the clips
yes subscribe don't just like love
and don't hesitate to spread the word we
uh feel strongly that the platforms are
not necessarily allowing people to
uh see our content or not recommending
it the way they might in light of
certain patterns but anyway
you can counteract that by uh pointing
people to
darkhorse content that's right so i'll
be back in 15 minutes in the meantime
love the people whom you love actively
and eat real food and get outside
be well everyone